mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
houston viel vergnügen
[Applaus]
was macht ein schneemann in einem
hotelzimmer
er ist einsam
und teil einer kunstausstellung an einem
ungewöhnlichen ort im zürcher hotel
außerdem in unserer sendung kerner
walker im kunstmuseum basel und die zwei
leben der ansporn
wer war sie wirklich wohltäterin oder
mörderin
[Musik]
ja die schweizer fahne wird eingeholt
eine neue auch er wird gleich gehisst
was hat das nur zu bedeuten
wir kommen nach den kulturplatz
[Musik]
der hier oben auf dem dach des hotel
europe in zürich weht ein frischer wind
und eine fahne entworfen von der
künstlerin jessica diamond eine fahne
mit vier buchstaben lauf sie ist teil
einer ausstellung die hier an diesem
ungewöhnlichen ort stattfinden
das zürcher hotel beherbergt nicht nur
gäste und geheimnisse aus aller welt
sondern in den nächsten wochen auf kunst
in den zimmern in den gängen an der
rezeption
[Musik]
stefan hat direktorin des hotels ja
hallo schön dürfen wir hier sein
es wird hier eine fahne gehisst eine
neue ausstellung ist das ein akt der
freude dass es endlich wieder losgeht in
ihrem hotel ja unglaublich wir freuen
uns extrem ich muss auch sagen glauben
dass auf die kunstausstellung hier
modell euro ist für mich ein
herzensprojekt für alle beteiligten
es ist wirklich aus einer emotion
entstanden aus einer negativen situation
etwas positives zu kreieren und die
ausstellung heißt der lauf in details of
pünktchen pünktchen pünktchen
wofür stehen diese 15 natürlich lockt
eine times während corona es ist
entstanden ich weiß auch noch wie ich zu
der zeit im hotel büro saß das war mitte
oktober war absolut trist und ich habe
einfach versucht den mut nicht zu
verlieren
die branche bei uns ist ganze geschäft
ist zusammengebrochen und ich habe
einfach versucht eine idee zu finden was
mache ich mit lern hotelzimmern
wir realisieren eine kunstausstellung
das war also der erste gedanke und eine
künstlerin hat ja hier auch noch einen
input gegeben oder ihr zusammen wie kam
das zustande
ich hatte alicia frau kennengelernt
letzten sommer hier im hotel und
natürlich habe ich mit der idee
kunstausstellung grad an alicia frommes
gedacht hab ich einfach geschrieben und
es hat sich gemeldet sofort und war
begeistert und hat dann endlich den
stein ins rollen gebracht das ist ja
auch eine freundschaft gewachsen und sie
ist jetzt wieder hier und sie richtet ja
ja und ich würde einfach sagen wir
schauen uns mal an und irgendwas gemacht
die künstlerin alicia fragen ist
arbeitet interaktiv für ihre
performances und installationen die oft
soziale und politische missstände
thematisieren
auch die publikum dass es während der
pandemie kaum gibt
deshalb hat sie sich für diese
ausstellung etwas besonderes ausgedacht
[Musik]
hallo was für ein unglaubliches der hut
ist aus kupfer eine spezialanfertigung
worum geht es in ihrer ich verschicke
hoffnung einen hoffnungsschimmer für
alle menschen wie schön danke und die
idee entstand während der pandemie ja
als performance künstlerin arbeite ich
immer mit dem publikum und jetzt geben
wir die leute ihre adresse und ich
schicke ihnen hoffnung und ein kleines
geheimnis ein kunst geheimnis ich wollte
etwas für menschen machen die kunst
lieben weil sie einen hoffnungsschimmer
park fast alle museen und galerien sind
man offen dann wieder geschlossen
so dachte ich es ist der richtige moment
um etwas unsichtbares aber nützliches zu
kreieren
[Musik]
und jetzt zu einem ganz anderen thema
hotel sind ja voller geheimnisse wer
weiß was hinter all diesen türen
geschieht und welche geheimnisse die
gäste mit sich tragen
ja die geschichte die wir ihnen jetzt
erzählen ist eine geschichte voller
düsterer geheimnisse es ist die
geschichte der schweizer ärztin an
spoerri die in kenia zur berühmtheit
wurde ihre vergangenheit aber verschwieg
es gibt geschichten die sind zu gut um
wahr zu sein wie die geschichte der
schweizer ärztin an sperre für viele war
ansporn ein vorbild in kenia wo sie über
jahrzehnte als flying doctor arbeitete
wird sie verehrt wie eine heilige ihre
jugend verbrachte die tochter einer
schweizerin in frankreich wo sie
studierte und sich während des zweiten
weltkriegs der resistance anschloss dem
gefährlichen widerstand gegen die
deutsche besatzung
nach dem krieg lebte sie in der schweiz
im schoß ihrer wohlhabenden familie
studierte in basel tropenmedizin bevor
sie in afrika zur mama daktari wurde zur
mama doktor
ein langjähriger freund erinnert sich
sie war unglaublich großzügig und
unglaublich freundlich kinder lagen ihr
besonders am herzen
zehntausende rettete an sperre das leben
sie impft operiert zähne
sie ist unermüdlich
als sie im jahre 1999 stirbt ist sie
eine heldin
doch das ist nur die halbe geschichte
die andere geschichte der an sperre
beginnt 1943
sie wird als mitglied der résistance
verhaftet und ins konzentrationslager
ravensbrück eingeliefert ein ort des
schreckens ein lager nur für frauen
sie wurden erniedrigt und gefoltert
zehntausende starb gegen ende des
krieges wurden die zustände immer
schlimmer die westlichen gebiete und
damit auch die vielfach lange
haftstrafen hinter sich hatten lange
lager erlebnisse es kam im oktober 44
noch die transporte aus ungarn
also es fühlte sich immer mehr im sommer
44 war hier ein großes zelt aufgebaut
worden in der mitte des lagers in dem
zeitweise 4000 frauen eingepfercht waren
und die gesundheitszustände waren
verheerenden ravensbrück was an sperre
in ravensbrück erlebte weiß niemand
genau
sie schwieg
bis zu ihrem tod
wenn ich sie danach fragt machte sie das
manchmal war es richtig brenzlig wenn
sie sagte stell mir nie wieder diese
frage das geht dich nichts an
es hat nichts mit meiner arbeit für die
fliegenden ärzte zu tun es ist ohne
bedeutung war an sperre auf der flucht
vor ihren erinnerungen drei jahre nach
der befreiung von ravensbrück verließ
sie europa und kehrte nie wieder zurück
sie ging in den jemen dann nach
äthiopien dann nach kenia in kenia
kaufte sie eine kleine propellermaschine
versorgte pro jahr 20.000 patienten
an spoerri ein nazi opfer dass
zehntausende leben rettet eine gute
geschichte zu gut um wahr zu sein
[Musik]
nach spohr ist tot entdeckt john
hemingway gerichtsprotokolle in denen
unfassbares steht unter dem decknamen
doktor claude habe sich spoerri in
ravensbrück so ist zu lesen
grauenhaft benommen sie habe die übrigen
insassen geschlagen und hunderte mit
ihren einspritzungen ums leben gebracht
die amerikaner fanden sogar nach ihr als
kriegsverbrechen
ich fand ein dokument auf dem ganz oben
stand zentrales verzeichnis der
verdächtigen von kriegsverbrechen
ich ging die liste durch darauf standen
norweger spanier italiener und eine
einzige schweizer an maria gesucht ein
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit und
folter
[Musik]
1947 ist sie wieder in der schweiz und
lebt in diesem haus in männedorf sie
wird verhaftet und verhört der
journalistinnen fabiano resch und judith
kormann haben den fall spoerri für die
nzz rekonstruiert und die
ermittlungsakten im staatsarchiv zürich
gesichtet
die dokumente eines fragwürdigen
verfahrens
seit die hiermit lege sie zurzeit sind
das historische statik trek xi wenn man
die aktuell ist relativ schnell dass
motivation und der zentrale von der
staatsanwaltschaft habe und die schwere
vorwürfe caritas schweiz sprechen dass
die motivation nicht zerstörungs
praktisch gesehen
mehrere frauen sagen aus sie habe andere
häftlinge eigenhändig getötet
kann das sein an spoerri führte im lager
mehrere leben soll eine liebesbeziehung
mit der berüchtigten kamen mori begonnen
haben auch sie schweizerin mori ist
block älteste eine art vorsteherin und
soll bis zu 60 häftlinge ermordet haben
nach dem krieg wird sie von einem
britischen militärgericht zum tode
verurteilt ihrer hinrichtung entgeht sie
durch selbstmord
in den ermittlungsakten findet sich ein
brief von carmen nori ein ansporn die
damals in basel ihr studium beendete
liebe kleine an schreibt sie und ich
umarme dich tausendmal
ganz deine kamen eine gewisse doktor
claude sei das beschreiben die
protokolle der zeugenaussagen die
komplizin der carmen mori gewesen und dr
claude sei ohne zweifel an sperren
doch die schweizer staatsanwälte wollen
den belastungszeugen keinen glauben
schenken
sie seien kommunistinnen deshalb
unglaubwürdig
außerdem wurden kurz nach dem krieg nur
wenige täterinnen angeklagt
geschlechterspezifische sich dass es
dass die taten er den männern
zugeschrieben und frauen vielleicht eher
als mitläuferin gesehen worden
was auffällt ist dass die frauen die vor
gericht kam dass es oftmals recht
schillernde persönlichkeiten waren und
haben kamen mori angesprochen die mit
pelzmantel vor gericht stand die als
fatalen stück weit dort auch beschrieben
wurde in der presse gegen ansprüche gibt
es nur zeugenaussagen keine anderen
beweise
1947 kommt sich frei lassen
der akt und damit mit historiker gerät
das das schon die die geistige haut mit
schweiz zu der zeit widerspiegelt aber
das zieht rasse reflexion über die
eigene tirol vor der schweizerin groß
aber der schweizerinnen und schweizer
leben im clean war der zweite weltkrieg
in deutschland
die hot chip sektor für eine genauere
slogan
in afrika soll sie zehntausenden das
leben gerettet haben macht es unrecht
ungeschehen wenn man erst leben nimmt
und wann leben rettet
auf diese frage fand wohl auch an
spoerri niemals eine antwort
[Musik]
wir sind zurück im zürcher hotel erhob
in der ausstellung lauf in der times of
diese verloren scheinendes schneemann
ist eine arbeit von jahren tiefer manche
zimmer kann man ganz normal buchen
andere sind für die kunst reserviert
nein dieser suite lebte einst die
ballettlegende rudolf nurejew immer dann
wenn er einen auftritt an der zürcher
oper hatte
nicht über das zürcher opernhaus aber
über die andere zürcher traditionsbühne
wird aktuell heftig gestritten soll der
zaun das stammhaus des zürcher
schauspielhauses nun abgerissen
renoviert oder einfach so gelassen
werden darüber gehen die meinungen
richtig weit auseinander
wenige kennen dieses haus so gut wie er
seit 15 jahren ist der baustein
technischer direktor am schauspielhaus
zürich
großes theater hat er entstehen sehen
und doch weiß er um die tücken der
pfarren bühne alles entsteht auf engstem
raum alle zufrieden stellen
die quadratur des kreises die sicht auf
die bühne ist das hauptproblem
das betrifft auch den boden in diesem
boden sieht man nur vom balkon aus
deswegen ist bodengestaltung bei uns
auch ein schwieriges thema eigentlich
müsste man dann schrägen machen um den
boden zu zeigen aber durch die schrägen
den hinten die darsteller zu hoch ist
es fängt sich jemand wie ein unmögliches
spiel wenn man eine sache verbessert hat
man das problem wieder an einer anderen
stelle und das hat viel mit der
geometrie des zuschauerraums mit der
größe des portals zu tun
viele problemzonen kennt der zaun
auf den günstigen plätzen fühlt man sich
manchmal wie im hörspiel auf den
teureren wie ein frosch wo auch immer
der energiefluss zwischen künstlern und
publikum schwierig nur vorne und auf der
mitte der bühne sind die schauspieler
wirklich von allen zu sehen und zu hören
[Musik]
arbeiten im frauen eine logistische
strapaze denn eine hinter und eine
zweite nebenbühne fehle
das macht umbauten aufwendig probezeiten
kurz die lösung mehr platz ließ er sich
durch eine tiefgreifende veränderung des
saales schaffen
deswegen wäre das ideal dass man den
saal wir heute ist nimmt was nicht geht
technisch und ihn anhebt in den ersten
stock bringt die bühne nimmt sie heute
ist in den ersten stock bringt unter
thronte transport und logistik wege hat
und ein großzügiges foyer was für die
anzahl der besucherin und ihre
bedürfnisse ausreicht das wäre ein traum
die zürcher stadtregierung will diesen
traum erfüllen nur die fassade des
hauses erhalten und das innere komplett
neu bauen
der denkmalschutz des gebäudes soll
dafür aufgehoben werden
freude bei den einen empörung bei
anderen für denkmalschützer aber auch
manche theaterleute ist ein solcher
eingriff respektlos und auch unnötig
denn der frauen steckt voller
erinnerungen und geschichte
ich erinnere mich gut wenig die hälfte
auf see hat uns friedeburg und wie
publikum das ist 740 vierjährige sie das
auch nicht vergaß das ist wie sehr es
die industry club lippe ins labor für
ihn und seine mitkämpfer muss der saal
erhalten werden denn hier wurde
theatergeschichte geschrieben
die große therese giehse in die physiker
von tun hat andor von max frisch die
stücke der grossen schweizer dramatiker
feierten hier premiere
auch einige stücke brechts kamen hier
zum ersten mal auf die bühne
während des nationalsozialismus fand
sich ein einzigartiges ensemble von
schauspielern und schauspielerinnen
zusammen und das haus wurde zum hort des
antifaschistischen widerstands ein zeuge
des liberalen offenen zürich
der russe gründlicher lag das juwel hand
muss auf der ganzen welt nie geklärt wie
viel über neutral hat müssen sie hat
sich das ermöglicht das gibt's nur da
und starrt sie dort ja gut da da das
hegen und pflegen und bei sony hat
bevölkerung wurde dazu nicht gemacht
die emotionen schlagen hoch hängt die
erinnerung an die großen zeiten am
konkreten raum wie hält man die
geschichte für künftige besucher im
bewusstsein wie viel samt braucht es
dafür wie viel veränderung verträgt der
zaun
die literaturwissenschaftlerin ursula am
rhein hat ganze bücher über die
geschichte dieses ortes geschrieben die
heftige diskussion ums theater findet
sie eigentlich produktiv und materiellen
es ihm materiell historische besser und
ich überlege das theater hätten große
vergangenheit aber das theater auch
nicht deutsch geblieben das muss sich
entwickeln es muss lebendig sie für die
stadt und meine für eine tiefe griffen
die familie ich muss man festhalten
es bleibt an bord die städtebauliche
randbebauung blieb gehalt erhalten da
die struktur auf um die klassische
stadttheater fest mit der guckkasten
könig
dass der zaun renoviert wird steht außer
frage wie tief greifend er verändert
wird das wird zürich die nächsten jahre
beschäftigen
der aktuelle künstlerische leiter kommt
von außen er hat keine
kindheitserinnerungen in plüsch benjamin
von blomberg wird hier nicht mehr
theater machen wenn es mal soweit ist in
mehr als zehn jahren
wir müssen auf visionen vertrauen und
das macht die debatte gerade so
schwierig ich glaube wenn wir über
visionen sprechen würden und nicht davon
was man verliert sondern im schönsten
fall ein wo fette und sieht was das sein
könnte
das würde glaube ich so etwas anderes
bedeuten weil plötzlich würde man spüren
es gibt sehr wohl orte die wieder zu dem
gleichen gefühl der verbundenheit fühlen
könnten
es geht darum in die zukunft zu denken
ohne zürichs bedeutendes erbe zu
vergessen wenn sich beide seiten
zusammen finden ja dann könnte ein
theater entstehen dass auch künftige
generationen noch bewegt vom tv jetzt
wieder zurück ist sich aus seefeld und
zwar ist linzer hauptplatz immer vom
hotel europa und ich bin damit dem turn
jetzt er sitzt auf dem bett an jetzt sie
hatte so meine ruh notiert art basel
unter freiem himmel ist das hotel wie
sind sie vorgegangen
das ist jetzt bürgerliches
gesamtkunstwerk mit tapete und lampen
liegt und somit für mich dass bereiche
wie sie sehr authentisch russischen
wunderbare folie
ich habe mich entschieden rechte geht es
gar nicht versuchen in estland und
ostritz pass sondern sie die weste
sprangen und der klerus theilig verzählt
auf und von der liebe empfunden was ist
botschaft vor dem ständig die
ausstellung entstanden werden lockt an
und frage sie was gibt es überhaupt noch
viel liebe und wie wird hier wie möglich
gemacht und was gibt es für neue
romantische narrativ du die
unmöglichkeit von sich nach kommen sich
kann allein weil man sich
das know-how und die traube überhaupt
neue wie erfahren wir haben es ist herz
öffnen neue mensch und es gibt die
ausstellung verantwortlich jetzt vom
letzten jahren speziell für mich es
wichtig die gesellschaft im 21
jahrhundert bilder als da gibt es eine
nummer zwei geschlechter sondern
angesagte mode es gibt verschiedene
rechtliche liebe und das gibt
romantische gmbh für mich ist wichtig
sind irgendeine romeo und julia fahrt
stoppen sondern hat wirklich das breite
rat gab sich gleichzeitig auch nur
stetig wo hat fantasie anregt und weil
bilder im kopf schießt und ich glaube
das ist wichtig wie in der new stellen
dass die grenze sprang mit dem hotel wo
sie kuratieren das zeigt auch der ruhm
durch lindstrom was ihr 36 bild krankt
hand von der leyen julien wieso das bild
am julianischen jüngste bronx in die
schlacht bekannte new york und es geht
natürlich um die sehr starke farbe aber
es geht darum die hutfarbe schönes thema
bären und um der rassismus für sie
erläutern was immer noch erlaubt
gleichzeitig hat das bilder waisenheims
lustvolles wie die farbe spritzt die
sich folglich und sie das lustvolle bin
ich mit einmal der bei ähnlichen
einzigartige kombination dankbar für
mein herz und viel spaß viel erfolg mit
husten dankbar seien julien gehört zur
jungen generation von afroamerikanischen
künstlerinnen ihre themen rassistischen
stereotypen oft auch aus
autobiografischer perspektive ja und
dort trifft sie sich mit der künstlerin
caravaca deren zeichnungen sind aktuell
im kunstmuseum basel zu sehen auf den
ersten blick sind sie dekorativ
amüsant zuweilen bis einem das
schmunzeln vergeht die scherenschnitte
beschreiben die bestialität der
sklaverei in der geschichte der usa mit
solchen zitaten bildern ist karla borger
in den 90er jahren berühmt geworden
für sie ist rassismus bis heute tief
eingeschrieben in die us amerikanische
gesellschaft und doch schwer zu
thematisieren
politische kunst schreckt ultimativ ab
niemand will sich kunst anschauen die
sich eindeutig als politisch ankündigt
der karikatur der witz und diese floride
form des scherenschnitte oder der
silhouette dinge nicht ganz sichtbar zu
machen ist eine art list um die
aufmerksamkeit der leute zu erregen
im kunstmuseum basel zeigt sie nun
vorbereitung skizzen und zeichnungen der
letzten 30 jahre
es sind notizen aus der dunklen
geschichte amerikas weiß gegen schwarz
herren gegen die ausbeuter gegen
ausgebeutete erniedrigung und tod
immer basierend auf der hautfarbe
[Musik]
seit short und eine präsidentin der den
rassismus mehr anfeuert als ein denkt
ist für walker der weg in die dunkle
vergangenheit amerikas so offen wie
lange nicht mehr
als ich in der 90er jahren zu arbeiten
anfing sagten die leute rassismus heute
ist viel leiser viel reduzierter ich
hörte dass immer wieder satte in welchem
universum lebt ihr es scheint als ob es
25 30 jahre gedauert hat bis heute
realisierten es gibt eine art verdeckte
sprache in der politik
die leute haben bemerkt wie heimlich
rassistische ideen kommuniziert werden
ein wendepunkt schien barack obama ein
hoffnungsschimmer am himmel der rassen
debatte carroll walker versuchte seine
bedeutung ins bild zu setzen
ich dachte an die metaphorik für die
obama stand als mensch als präsident und
als ikone als eine art erfüllung einer
amerikanischen prophezeit nach der
hoffnung kann die gegenreaktion
obama wird durch eine rhetorik von rasse
und zugehörigkeit vom sockel gestoßen
[Musik]
er wurde ersetzt
es war fast wie ein ko seines
nachfolgers des 45 präsident dieser
person die diese lügen erfüllte kampagne
über obamas herkunft führt und dass
seine wahl von anfang an nicht legitim
dass alles eingepackt in dieser
amerikanischen mythologie von rasse und
authentizität
die letzten vier jahre waren für viele
leute einfach ein schrecklicher
skandalöse alptraum
michael kist die rassismus debatte in
eine ästhetische fahren die gleichzeitig
umwerfend als auch anklagend ist so hat
sie in new york in einer alten
zuckerfabrik das rassistische symbol
einer untertägigen schwarzen sklaven in
40 tonnen weißen zucker gegossen
doch für diese schönheit des schreckens
zu einer nachhaltigen debatte über
rassismus
das problem mit der zeit ist die
müdigkeit die rassismus möglichkeit
jeder will dass alles wieder gut und
glücklich wird und dieses gut normal und
glücklich ist das was gut normal und
glücklich das ist das was längst nicht
ausreicht
[Musik]
ja das war unser versuch hier im zürcher
hotel europa die kunst sich einquartiert
und flagge zeigt die ausstellung läuft
bis zum 20 juni mein artist einchecken
er nächste woche da geht es bei uns um
die weiblichen wechseljahre viele
klischees viele tabus und ich freue mich
wenn sie dann auch wieder mit dabei sind
gleich hier auf als f1 geht jetzt weiter
mit der dänischen serie die wege des
herrn
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]